black widows multilayered and you know
motivated and determined and all of
those things and she has an art I would
love to take this character in every
different direction you always picking
up after you boys the possibilities are
really endless before I worked for
shield make mistakes but I'm done
running from my past very few actors can
say that they've worked on a character
for 10 years and then suddenly have this
chance to delve deep into the inner
workings of this person we have to go
back to where it all started there's one
movie people have been asking us to make
for very long time more so than any
other film the black widow movie
we're gonna be able to create something
that is a different flavor for the
Marvel Universe I'm just excited to see
the real Black Widow she's not a classic
hero because she has a dark past what
brings you home you get to see all these
facets of her that we've never ever seen
before
we have unfinished business one thing's
for sure it's gonna be a hell of a
reunion Marvel Studios Black Widow in
theaters May 1st